[Musique]
alors mathieu donc mathieu est ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
dans touche pas à mon poste il va nous
regarder il va voir tout ce que vous
dites bien sûr alors il ya des bonnes
idées mauvaise idée angela bonne idée
mauvaise idée pour gilles verdez
mauvaise idée pour sur l'udc attention
on y va boni alors vous savez les
oreilles sinon elle voulait toujours un
truc et à l'autre qui dit quand même
j'ai toujours un truc qui me dérange pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je ne sais pas
brusquement sommes à gratter à est
d'accord vous avez des chaînons dans
l'émission sera bonne ou mauvaise idée
alors mathieu qui était sur nrj 12
alors même mois il le sait très bien ya
quelques années je pouvais pas
l'encadrer comme moi c'était partie des
gens qui mettent des petites mares dans
la charge ou à décharge l'écouté j'ai
trouvé que c'était un garçon intelligent
maintenant je le mets ya déjà un an
disait que c'était dommage si on lui
faisait faire là bas donc c'est normal
que ça content qu'il soit là julien
bonne idée pour une agence m6 on doit
chacun de donner un avis sur la télé en
tant que entre guillemets spécialistes
c'est un spécialiste de la téléréalité
moi j'avais jamais produit je peux
difficilement parler je peux vous parler
de jeux je peux pas les bonnes choses
que je pense qu'il aura des trucs à dire
sur la télé réalité particulièrement
chaos bonne idée je pense que c'est une
stratégie gagnante tout ce qu'il a fait
il s'en est quand même pris plein la
tête
il ya certaines personnes qui ont pensé
qu'il était un peu mort donc je pense
que c'était ce qui pouvait lui arriver
de mieux d'arriver dans cette équipe en
revanche moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
parti va cracher dans la soupe de la
télé réalité et de toutes ces chaînes
comme nrj12 et caetera et se refaire un
nouveau personnage ou s'il va rester
fidèle à ce qui fait depuis des années
et qu'à mauvaise idée vous vous voulez
bien revenir mais pas lui
pas de place pour tout le monde mais
mathieu on n'a pas ces mauvaises années
ensemble jta energy avec lui ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pris avec mon nom
soit pas été quelqu'un de sympa avec moi
c'est vraiment on en a discuté la gelée
vu tout à l'heure je pense que les
vacances qu'on fait du bien on je pense
qu'on en est sur un bon terrain
mais c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas été top
ben sur son sur son plateau laquelle n'a
pas été terrible et c'est pas quelqu'un
qui disait bonjour facilement je
commençais à erika elle fait une très
bonne recrue
j'adore vraiment mal dit la vérité
voyons ensemble les gens comme l'étude
ici on a fait le clip en somme on a
rigolé main non pas du tout on n'attaque
pas du tout du moins laissez moi non je
parle aussi de la télé ça se ressent
aussi donc je parle vraiment aussi de
l'homme qu'il est il n'a pas été cool
avec moi et c'est vrai que ça s'est
ressenti parce que même les
téléspectateurs me le disait quant au
respect c'est possible et donc voilà
mais maintenant voilà on s'est tenu par
la main on a dit qu'on avait voulu
d'aller vite on est voilà on va passer à
autre chose mais sur le coup il le sait
très bien il n'a pas été cool donc
mauvaise idée donc ça ça vous fait chier
de le voir tous les jours
non parce que ça va vous allez faire des
émissions au sort ou pas où je moi je
vous sais pas non je pense que c'est
bien justement il faudrait font grand
océan boys et alors enora bonne idée je
suis étonné oui parce que moi je me fous
de l'humain ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
travail avec le halal par l'étonnant
mais elle compte c'est son point de vue
mais moi je trouve que ça va être génial
pour moi je vais pouvoir m'embrouiller
justement sur la télé réalité avec le
spécialiste de latéralité on est on
n'aime pas du tout la même chose je
pense qu'on va être d'accord sur à peu
près rien du tout donc embellie pour
l'émission je trouve et puis pour lui
c'est bien qu'il fasse autre chose il
était complètement fermée à nrj12 en
faisant des choses très médiocres là il
a une nouvelle vie devant lui c'est top
jean-luc mauvaise idée mathieu de
l'envoi dans touche pas aux pales un
point très honnête il est resté en
plateau est cité en face de moi je redis
bonne idée là il est sorti donc des
idées je n'ai rien à [ __ ] parce que
globalement je crois je m'en fous un peu
c'est ma cinquième
rentrée avec touche pas à mon poste et
j'ai appris avec le temps de s'attacher
aux nouveaux sais pas c'est pas que les
pas complètement saoul est très vite
bonne idée ou d'un mot puisque les
bonnes idées ici chez moi intéressante
les mauvaises idées
évidemment évidemment pas où je pense
que ça est une délivrance comme vous le
disiez pour lui tout a l'air donc c'est
une très bonne idée le centre aéré je
pense qu'il en avait marre
et puis a toujours dit je sais faire
autre chose donc bonne idée on a envie
de voir ce que ça donne matière à un mot
sur autre chose
moi je me suis super bonne idée parce
qu'on va s'apercevoir que c'est pas
uniquement à un interviewer à cagole de
la télé réalité c'est un producteur
talentueux et en plus un journaliste de
la presse écrite je me souviens de ses
chroniques dans paris match sur la télé
qui était très bonne rien donc on va on
va apprendre de lui alors gilles vous
mauvaise idée très mauvaise idée
c'est une sorte de sous l'habile a donc
il faut arrêter quoi il est en dessous
la villa mais qui va être extrêmement
langue de bois
ouais c'est un mauvais débatteurs bon
animateur
j'y crois pas une seconde c'est pas vrai
il a toujours assumé le second degré
snes qui l'a présenté sur tout à fait
intéressante parce qu'on habite a été
l'âge il était super potable avec papa
et je pense qu'il a moins envie de pécho
de matthieu delormeau kabila il n'est
pas langue de bois du tout machester
alors qu'avant il il est pas langue de
bois va signer pour moi je trouve que
c'est une mauvaise idée parce que je
pense ce garçon manque de recul et
second degré justement la première fois
qu'il est venu sur ce plateau
c'était l'époque de france 4 il a fondu
en larmes quand on aura la charge et moi
je trouve que le mec qu'a pas ça prouve
que c'est loin d'être humain elle va où
il est justement lui raté rible à 14h45
d'êtres humains donc voilà comment alors
oui et moi je trouve ça assez dommage et
je suis sûr effectivement qui ne qui ne
crachera pas dans la soupe
il va il va continuer à rester planté
sur ses à nous dire que tellement vrai
c'est vrai par exemple
et rien que ça déjà ça rayer les
abeilles ça fait sept ans qui me vend
même plus de sept ans qui me vend des
programmes de merde qui me pourrissent
la vie je veux dire donc nous retrouver
avec lui là franchement excusez moi mais
symbole alors qu'en mai
angela blé pas dit vous moi rien que
qu'il existe ce débat sur mathieu je me
dis qu'il a tout gagné et je suis pour
puisque d'abord je pense que c'est un
grand professionnel après j'étais pas je
vais pas ce qu'il faisait sur sur les
anges je dois dire je le dis maintenant
j'ai presque tout le monde a droit à
faire d autre chose a changé
il a un regard sur la télé j'ai produit
en programmes dans lesquels il était
chroniqueur il est excellent je trouve
qu'il a sa place et rien que parce que
vous aimez pas j'adore voilà donc à rien
que parce qu'on fait ces débats là je
trouve qu'il a vraiment sa place
voilà parce qu'on fait le débat vous
trouvez qu'il a sa place allez bon va
l'accueillir tout de suite allé matthieu
delormeau qui est annexée
[Applaudissements]
quant à mathieu problème et assume
aujourd'hui mon adjoint matières
premières et 4 la foire le prenait à un
tiers premier cas sur mon genou ça va
faire du verseau faire du rab à mathieu
honnêtement oui car denner sa rue quand
vous êtes hyper v lire mais non mais
t'as entendu des trucs non mais juste
pour commencer avec christophe plus dans
trois secondes
je veux quand tu veux dire que tu es
demanderait c'est vrai parce que je le
produit est donc je sais ce que je
produis je mens pas je sais pas langue
de bois mais on avait voulu attends je
termine si tu avais voulu en septembre
plutôt que juste poser tes fesses et
commentés venir une seule fois assister
un tournage pour voir que c'est vrai qu
assister journaliste tu regardes les
faits si c'est vrai c'est vrai si c'est
pas vrai tu dénonces mais en
l'occurrence même la soirée d'annoncé du
jeu
mais pour revenir juste une fois vérifié
et juste pour rien sur le terrain
c'était sûr à mathieu quand je vais sur
les journalistes américains pillant
bruxellois tu dis et je vais sur un
tournage a priori parce que j'aime ou le
film ou l'émission lac
excuse moi dans une revue dont une où il
ya à mes yeux tu produis de la merde
qu'est ce que tu bruit nazis c'est de la
merde mais elle vient vérifier que c'est
le fallait bien truquée ces bruits ne
vient d'accorder attendez attendez
attendez
isabelle morini bosc non non alors la
tma le net 8le n'est pas ce que c'est de
la merde je sens que c'est pas de ma vie
c'est de la merde avait promis dimanche
que porte une accusation exactly jeunes
la poubelle a prouvé son pays est en
faillite en des lieux qu'éprouve le ya
pas eu de treillis pas m'attarder n'est
jamais venu sur les toits il ya eu pas
mal d'articles n'ont pas été pour celui
mais je m'en fous tellement vrai je peux
vous dire c'est sait si généralement
frais après il refoule mercer lui n'est
jamais payé je le jure sur ma tête je me
sens mes neveux je n'ai jamais payé je
te dis blacks q les notions je n'ai
jamais truqués quelque chose viril a dit
quelqu'un va venir vérifier bien en
l'occurrence c'est très facile de
critiquer quand y en a un à qui on
demande de bouger son cul pour venir sur
un tournage et de vérifier s'il ya plus
personne
une information c'est pas une rumeur qui
deviennent un fossé on vérifie ça
devienne fou ça devient l'inspecteur
barnaby oui
[Rires]
oui voulait dire quelque chose france
minimes moi je trouve que c'est très
réducteur ce que tu dis christophe parce
que tellement vrai le résumé a de la
merde comme ça moi je suis désolé elle
me souviens de documents predator ya que
mathieu a produit avec adriana karembeu
way où elle revenait dans la ville
d'origine et appliqué de qualité et je
pense qu'ils à faire des documentaires
de qualité sur nrj12 aussi d'ailleurs
dira ce qu'on voudra mais on sait
accueillir les nouveaux
[Applaudissements]
est ce que je peux dire un dernier mot
après je vous dis juste un truc je dis
chaque année ne me fait jamais ça
commence à jamais préfère rouler là sous
les genres ça genre ça n'est pas ça oui
après la langue de bois et merci
évidemment pour tout ce qu'on dit des
mots gentils et quant à erika jeu mais
j'hallucine de ma vie on ne s'est croisé
deux fois je n'ai jamais animé une
émission avec toi tu sais même pas
comment les gens on peut dire que tu es
mal accueillie je n'ai jamais fini mais
5 twh été croisé deux fois dans ma vie
je ne t'ai jamais vu une fois nrj 12
alors que tu es une antipathie c'est
possible mais que tu penses que tu viens
de dire si un juge allemand s'est croisé
deux fois dans nos vies on a parlé sur
le clip là tu sais que je t'ai dit
écoute comment ça se fait que à ce point
tu mets paru si désagréable et j'attends
et je tenais les exemples je t'ai dit tu
sais qu'il voulait pas l'appeler ce soir
gilbert mathieu tu faisais moi mais là
on pointe le problème dès qu'on dit
quelque chose sur vous
trois heures de justification
[Applaudissements]
john cette rentrée si un gars au dracula
le gars vous n'acceptez pas vous
n'acceptez pas de débat mozilla va doit
c'est une chimie n'acceptez pas le débat
excepté pas le débat ouais je sais la
reçois cette rentrée est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
se fait défoncer par tout moyen à lomé
direct lors que leurs confrères sans
merci les officiers crème des biens
walla et devaient fermer ma gueule parce
que c'est pas agréable
moi je lui dis déjà chapeau de ré de
garder ton sang froid parce que moi
j'aurais mis déjà 3 par aline dans le
buffet de plus long terme émis 3 praline
parce que je paye grille était garé en
double file avec la avec les patins pour
pardon plume car ça c'est que l'on a
dépassé car professionnel gilles me sens
donc moi je te dis bienvenue et
j'adorerais qu on s'embrouille ensemble
toute l'année femme alors aller et
mathieu mathieu je me sens j'ai invité à
gatineau
c'est le gars passe mal le dîner c'est
bien là normalement j'arrive lâcher ce
que vous êtes débutant
[Rires]